how's it going everyone I'm not sure if
you all have seen this photo or not that
the rooster brothers just post it but
it's driving me crazy
so here's the deal today the rooster
brothers took to Instagram and Twitter
and posted a photo with the caption look
hard and it's pretty much been freaking
the whole entire internet out ever since
it was posted real quick just a reminder
about the giveaway I'm giving away a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
some special memorabilia and a special
poster as well all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
okay so I've stared at this poster for
over an hour
really I have I have messed with the
brightness the contrast the hue I have
messed around with this thing I've
turned it upside down I've rotated it
I've zoomed in on every possible corner
or small detail that I could find and my
editor has done the same everyone's
saying that this photo has the title in
it this has the Avengers 4 title in it
so everyone has just been dissecting it
as much as they can so we'll kind of
walk through everything that I've tried
to do to figure out what it is ok so
let's start off with the obvious the A's
a lot of people say that you can clearly
see forays and I think you can but after
going through a bunch of comments on
this photo a lot of people see like ten
different A's and I don't think there's
ten A's I think that's kind of pushing
it a little bit and if you go with the
whole for a theory that makes sense
because Avengers 4 then you see this
little tiny X here and a lot of people
are going x-men x-men but we're not
gonna have the x-men and Avengers 4 it's
just not going to happen the Disney Fox
deal isn't even entirely done yet and to
me this X is just a mark that the
production crew uses now some people say
that there are just really two A's in
this the obvious a is the latter and the
canvas in front of Joe Russo here and I
could probably agree with that now
obviously the first thing that comes to
my mind is a
Jers assemble but the Russo brothers
have already come out and said that the
title of Avengers 4 is going to scare us
and Avengers Assemble doesn't really
scare me and then you have some people
that think endgame is spelled out and I
think that's really pushing it I just
don't see it I don't see how Joe Russo
is a G here I just don't I think that's
really pushing it and besides the Russo
brothers have said that the title of
Avengers 4 it was not mentioned in
Avengers infinity war so Doctor Strange
said we're in the endgame now so it was
mentioned and Avengers endgame doesn't
really scare me either
so I don't think that's it maybe it's
not a title we should be looking for
maybe it's a clue to something else like
there's these pictures on this canvas
maybe there's something on these
pictures now what actually interests me
the most about this picture is this
machine in the back that says nachi on
it so I did a little bit of research and
notching North America Inc is a machine
company and they actually manufacturer
robotics this to me seems like it could
be one of Tony Stark's machines perhaps
he'll try to make an infinity stone or
the Infinity Gauntlet like some supposed
to plot League say but then again this
could possibly just be equipment used by
the production crew who really knows
what I actually think it is is if you
look at the ladder on the right the
right next to Jill Russo there's actual
writing on it right behind his chair and
what it seems to say is Messi M II S II
and that means month in Italian so if
you take the ladder as an A and the
writing as month then you get a month so
perhaps we're going to get the title in
a month we're not going to get the
trailer for Avengers 4 before we get the
title that just won't happen and we're
not going to get the trailer for
Avengers 4 before we get another
detailed Captain Marvel trailer so to me
this kind of makes the most sense
because you do have to look hard at that
ladder to see that writing on it so it
stands out from all the other writing on
because it looks like it's hand drawn so
that's what I'm going with
again I've looked at this picture for
over an hour but let's come up with
something together what do you all see
let's see if we can figure this out
together let me know what you all see in
the comments below for now I'm saying
that this photo says we get the title in
a month I don't think it actually
divulges the title but again let me know
your thoughts another reminder about the
giveaway if you would like to enter all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]
you